>>> NEW REPORTING UNDERCUTTING A
KEY TRUMP CLAIM ABOUT CLASSIFIED
DOCUMENTS FOUND AT MAR-A-LAGO.
THE FORMER PRESIDENT AND ITS
ALLIES HAVE INSISTED FALSELY
THAT THE GENERAL SERVICES AGENCY
PACKED THOSE BOXES THAT WERE
ULTIMATELY SENT TO HIS FLORIDA
ESTATE MAR-A-LAGO.
NOW THE AGENCY HAS RELEASED
HUNDREDS OF PICTURES OF FILES
THAT SIMPLY WAS NOT THE CASE.
CNN'S KRISTEN HOLMES IS HERE.
WHAT HAVE YOU LEARNED AND WHY IS
IT SIGNIFICANT?
>> IN BETWEEN THE PAGES OF
MINUTIA ABOUT OFFICE SUPPLIES
AND WHAT'S GOING WHERE, THERE IS
DWIGHT A BIT, THAT CLAIM FROM
TRUMP AND HIS ALLIES THAT THE
FORMER PRESIDENT COULDN'T
POSSIBLY BE HELD RESPONSIBLE FOR
ANYTHING THAT WAS FOUND
CLASSIFIED DOCUMENTWISE BY THE
FBI AT MAR-A-LAGO BECAUSE HE
SIMPLY DID NOT PACK THOSE BOXES.
NOBODY IN HIS ORBIT PACKED THEM.
IT WAS DONE BY THE GSA THE SMALL
AGENCY THAT HELPS WITH
TRANSITION.
AND THEY WERE THE ONLY ONES THAT
DID THIS AND NOBODY KNEW
ANYTHING ABOUT IT.
THESE DOCUMENTS DEBUNK THAT
CLAIM.
I WANT TO PULL UP THAT PICTURE
BECAUSE THIS IS HOW THE GSA
FOUND THE BOXES WHEN THEY
ARRIVED TO MOVE THEM.
YOU COULD TELL HERE, THEY WERE
NOT UNPACKED IN ANY WAY.
THEY ARE COMPLETELY PACKED, THEY
ARE LABELED AND THEY ARE SHRINK
WRAPPED WAITING FOR THE GSA TO
PICK THEM UP THIS CAME FROM A
TRUMP AIDE WHO WAS SHOWING THE
GSA WHAT IT WAS THAT NEEDED TO
BE MOVED AND TRANSPORTED DOWN TO
FLORIDA.
NOW, THERE ARE A COUPLE OF
INTERESTING FINDINGS, I WANT TO
NOTE.
ONE OF THEM, THIS IS ABOUT THE
TIME LINE AND THE DATES ON THOSE
EMAILS.
WHILE WE KNOW NOW THAT THESE
BOXES WERE SIMPLY SITTING ON
PALLETS IN AN EFFORT OFFICE
SPACE SHRINKED INCLUDING 30
BANKERS BOXES WHICH ARE THE TYPE
OF BOXES RETRIEVED BY THE FBI
THIS IS HAPPENING AT THE EXACT
SAME TIME THAT THE NATIONAL
ARCHIVES WAS STARTING TO RAISE
ALARMS, RAISED CONCERNS THAT
THEY WERE MISSING PART OF THE
PRESIDENT'S RECORDS.
WHAT'S INTERESTING THAT NEVER
COMES UP, DOCUMENTS NEVER COME
UP IN THE EXCHANGES BACK AND
FORTH BUT WHAT DOES COME IS THE
NATIONAL ARCHIVES.
THIS IS RAISED BECAUSE AN AIDE
ASKED THE GSA IF IT WOULD BE
WILLING TO TRANSPORT A
300-POUND, 6 FOOT BY 8 FOOT
PORTRAIT OF TRUMP THAT HE
RECEIVED AS A GIFT DOWN TO
MAR-A-LAGO.
THE GSA SAID THEY WILL NOT DO
THAT.
THAT THAT IS A GIFT.
AND TALKS ABOUT THE RULES OF THE
NATIONAL ARCHIVES, WHAT GOES
THERE.
AND SAYS THAT'S PERSONAL
PROPERTY SO IT DOESN'T FALL IN
THE SAME CATEGORY BUT
INTERESTINGLY, NONE OF THOSE
DOCUMENTS EVER COME UP.
JOHN, I DO WANT TO NOTE, WE
CANNOT CONFIRM ANY OF THE
DOCUMENTS THAT WERE IN THOSE
BOXES WERE WHAT WAS RECOVERED BY
THE FBI OR TURNED OVER TO THE
ARCHIVES, BUT ALL OF THIS
HAPPENING AT THE SAME TIME.
>> THANK YOU FOR THAT REPORTING.
LET'S BRING FORMER STATE
PROSECUTOR ELLIE HONIG INTO THE
CONVERSATION.
OUR REPORTER IS HERE AS WELL.
ELIE, WE DON'T KNOW IF THE
DOCUMENTS WERE THESE, AND TRUMP
AND HIS ALLIES SAYING THE GSA
PACKED THE BOXES, THE GSA DID
THIS.
BUT THEN YOU HAVE THE VISUAL
PROOF THAT NO, THESE WERE
ACTUALLY PACKED UP BY THE TRUMP
TRANSITION AIDES.
IT'S A BORING EMAIL BUT VERY
IMPORTANT WHEN YOU TALK ABOUT
WHO DID WHAT, RIGHT?
>> YEAH, JOHN, IT'S CRUCIAL
BECAUSE IT GOES TO THE HEART OF
KNOWLEDGE.
THIS IS SOMETHING THAT
PROSECUTORS ARE LOOKING AT.
IF IN FACT IT WAS THE CASE THAT
GSA PACKED UP THE DOCUMENTS AND
TRANSPORTED THEM WITHOUT KNOWING
WHAT WENT DOWN TO MAR-A-LAGO
THAT WOULD BE A SIGNIFICANT
POINT IN DEFENSE OF DONALD TRUMP
AND THE PEOPLE AROUND HIM.
BUT, OF COURSE, THAT TURNS OUT
THAT IS NOT THE CASE AS KRISTEN
JUST REPORTED THERE ARE
DOCUMENTS SHOWING THAT THESE
DOCUMENTS WERE PACKED BY PEOPLE
AROUND DONALD TRUMP.
AND, FRANKLY, DONALD TRUMP AS
AB
ACKNOWLEDGED SUCH IN HIS
STATEMENT.
AND HE ACKNOWLEDGED THAT THEY
WERE MOVED TO MAR-A-LAGO PIPE
GUARANTEE PROSECUTORS ARE PAYING
ATTENTION TO IT.
>> WELL, PROSECUTORS ARE PAGE
ATTENTION TO THE GSA, THEY MIGHT
ALSO LISTEN TO THE FORMER
PRESIDENT, HE WAS OUT THIS
WEEKEND.
AND HE SAYS THERE'S NO CRIME
HERE AND I WANT MY DOCUMENTS
BACK.
>> NO CRIME.
YOU KNOW THERE'S NO CRIME.
IT'S NOT A CRIME.
AND THEY SHOULD GIVE ME
IMMEDIATELY BACK EVERYTHING
THEY'VE TAKEN FROM ME.
BECAUSE IT'S MINE.
IT'S MINE.
THEY TOOK IT FROM ME IN THE
RAID.
THEY BROKE INTO MY HOUSE.
>> ELIE, THEY LEGALLY SERVED A
SEARCH WARRANT THAT WAS ISSUED
BY A FEDERAL JUDGE, THEY DIDN'T
BREAK INTO HIS HOUSE, THEY
LEGALLY RECOVERED WHAT THEY
COULD RECOVER.
TO THE POINT WHERE THE FORMER
PRESIDENT SAYS IT'S MINE, IT'S
MINE.
IS IT HIS?
>> NO.
WELL, SOME OF IT ACTUALLY IS,
JOHN, A VERY SMALL PERCENTAGE OF
IT, BUT WE ACTUALLY LEARNED JUST
ON FRIDAY THAT THEY'RE NOW GOING
THROUGH THIS SPECIAL MASTER
PROCESS THERE IS A SET OF NARROW
DOCUMENTS THAT DONALD TRUMP AND
HIS TEAM AGREE WERE PERSONAL
PROPERTY OF DONALD TRUMP AND
THEY ARE BEING RETURNED TO
DONALD TRUMP.
HOWEVER, THAT IS A SMALL
FRACTION OF THE TOTAL DOCUMENTED
SEIZED AT MAR-A-LAGO.
THAT'S NOT THE ISSUE HERE.
BUT THEY'RE LOOKING AT
CLASSIFIED DOCUMENTS, THEY'RE
LOOKING AT THE SENSITIVE
DOCUMENTS WHICH BOTH SIDES IN
SOME CASES BELIEVE ARE NOT
DONALD TRUMP'S PROPERTY.
IT'S A MIXED DIRECTION HERE.
SOME PERCENTAGE WERE DONALD
TRUMP BUT THOSE AREN'T THE BULK
OF MATERIALS AND THOSE AREN'T
THE ONES THAT PROSECUTORS ARE
FOCUSED ON.
>> MISDIRECTION IS AN IMPORTANT
WORD.
ELIE, SAY WITH US.
ABOUT WHOSE DOCUMENTS THEY ARE,
JUST CONFUSED PEOPLE OUT THERE.
LISTEN TO DONALD TRUMP THIS
WEEKEND, SAYING I'M UNDER
INVESTIGATION.
HE TELLS HIS SUPPORTERS, WHAT
ABOUT THE OTHER PRESIDENTS?
>> WHEN WILL THEY INVESTIGATE
AND PROSECUTE BILL CLINTON,
HILLARY CLINTON, GEORGE BUSH AND
LOOK AT WHAT TOOK PLACE WITH
GEORGE BUSH'S FATHER, A VERY
NICE MAN AND THE WAREHOUSE OF
DOCUMENTS.
AND WHAT ABOUT BARACK HUSSEIN
OBAMA, UNDER POTENTIAL
PROSECUTION.
>> THIS IS CLASSIC TRUMP AND
MISDIRECTION, IN THE SENSE THAT
HE WANTS TO RUN FOR PRESIDENT
AGAIN.
HE KNOWS ALL OF THESE
INVESTIGATIONS, WE'LL SEE WHERE
THEY GET US SUBSTANTIVE BY THEN,
A LONG WAY 2024, SAYING THEY'RE
ALL CORRUPT.
EVERY INVESTIGATION.
WHERE ARE THE INVESTIGATIONS OF
EVERYBODY ELSE.
THIS IS A TIME-TESTED TRUMP
STRATEGY.
>> ABSOLUTELY.
THIS IS WHAT BROKE AFTER THE
DOCUMENTS THAT BROKE THAT THEY
MAY CONTAIN NUCLEAR SECRETS.
HE SAID BARACK OBAMA TOOK 30
MILLION RECORDS, WHAT ABOUT HIM.
ALL OF THIS MADE-UP STUFF.
I THINK HE'S TRYING TO DISTRACT
OR NORMALIZE WHAT'S HAPPENED TO
HIM OR POLITICIZE THE FBI THAT
THEY'RE ONLY GOING AFTER HIM,
BUT THEY HAVEN'T GONE AFTER
PREVIOUS PRESIDENTS FOR SIMILAR
CRIMES, MISDEMEANORS, WHATEVER
YOU WANT TO CALL IT WHICH IS
OBVIOUSLY NOT TRUE.
BUT LIKE YOU SAID, IT'S
MISDIRECTION, TRYING TO CONFUSE
HIS SUPPORTERS AND MISDIRECTION
FROM WHAT HAPPENED.
WHEN THIS HAPPENED, EVERYONE
THOUGHT THIS COULD BE GOOD FOR
TRUMP BUT OF COURSE THE DETAILS
CAME OUT AND IT'S BEEN VERY
DAMAGING.
>> WE KNOW GOING BACK TO THE
EARLY DAYS OF THE PRESIDENCY.
THAT HE OBSESSES ABOUT CROWDS.
CROWDS.
I WANT YOU TO LISTEN TO THIS
OBSESSION ABOUT THE CROWDS.
>> BIGGEST CROWD I'VE EVER
SEEN -- JANUARY 6.
AND YOU NEVER HEAR THAT.
THAT WAS THE BIGGEST.
AND THEY WERE THERE LARGELY TO
PROTEST A CORRUPT AND RIGGED AND
STOLE EVLECTION.
>> HE'S PROUD OF THE BIG CROWD
ON JANUARY 6th.
PART OF THAT CROWD ATTACKING THE
UNITED STATES GOVERNMENT
INJURED, BRUTALLY BEAT POLICE
OFFICERS.
THREATENED THE VICE PRESIDENT OF
THE UNITED STATES.
HE'S PROUD OF THAT.
>> YEAH, OF COURSE, HE WOULD SAY
HE'S REFERENCING THE CROWD THAT
PRECEDED THE RIOT.
BUT I THINK IT GOES TO SHOW THAT
HIS PRIORITIES ARE SOMETHING
THAT'S NOT REALLY ROOTED IN
POLICY GOVERNING, NOT ROOTED IN
THE TRUTH OFTEN.
IT'S ROOTED IN, YOU KNOW, JUST
KIND OF SELF-SATISFYING
BEHAVIOR, KIND OF.
YOU KNOW, IT'S JUST NOT
NECESSARILY WHAT WE THOUGHT WE
WOULD SEE FROM A FORMER
PRESIDENT.
BUT THIS IS CLASSIC DONALD
TRUMP.
>> WELL, AND THE STORY FOR TRUMP
IS NOT HIM, IT'S EVERYBODY
AROUND HIM.
WE KNOW DONALD TRUMP CARES MORE
ABOUT CROWDS THAN ANYTHING ELSE
BUT WHAT'S MORE TELLING IS IT'S
OCTOBER OF '22, HE'S GIVING THAT
SPEECH AFTER BEING IMPEACHED
TWICE.
LEAVING OFFICE IN DISGRACE.
AND THE STATEWIDE CANDIDATES IN
THE STATES ARE STILL SHOWING UP
WITH HIM, BECAUSE THERE'S MORE
OF A PENALTY POLITICALLY IN
THEIR MINDS FOR NOT SHOWING UP
THAN STANDING WITH HIM.
THAT, TO ME, IS THE BIGGEST
REVEAL OF THE STATE OF HIS PARTY
AND WHAT HE'S DONE IN THIS
PARTY.
WE KNOW WHAT DONALD TRUMP.
WHAT THE TELL IS HOW HE'S
RESHAPED ONE OF THE TWO PARTIES
IN THIS COUNTRY.